I think anyone who hasn't experienced
racism shouldn't say anything about it
full stop okay cool so I agree quite a
while five years five years in a black
neighborhood I got in a fight every
other day for it okay but that's because
I had red hair they called me a rooster
I literally got in fights every day so
you got bullied that's not racism
exactly
discrimination based on what it is
exactly where racism is it's not racism
they didn't stop he wasn't oppressed we
were the ones that oppressed so you
can't call that right how are you
oppressed in 2023 how are you oppressed
because I got news for you honey if you
had a skill set that was worth something
to somebody you would be the richest
[__] in here so say we didn't exist
that slavery exist slavery existed yeah
it also it also existed for Irish I'm
not trying to belittle what happened I
would never no I'm not no I'm not UK
talking slavery no no no no no here's
why there was no slaves here here's why